hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that i stumbled upon
yesterday
uh sorry about the position already
being on the board while browsing
twitter uh it's a game between hikaru
nakamura and shakira mamidarov it's a
three plus
zero uh game so three minutes plus zero
seconds increment uh
and for those of you who don't know uh
it's still very early but mamidarov also
has a youtube channel so do check it out
i will put a link to it in the
description below so you guys can check
out uh his content
and uh this is also one of the games
that's available there but i decided
to make a sort of a more of a detailed
analysis and also to invite you guys to
check out his channel
but this game it's such an amazing game
that uh
well it's been a while since we've seen
a game like this
played in modern times so without
further ado let's check it out and see
what's happening hikaru has the white
pieces
and he opens with e4 we have c6 by
mamidyarov going for the karo khan
knight to c3 d5 and now just knight to
f3
ignoring black's uh threat in the center
we have bishop to g4
uh all been seen before nothing out of
the ordinary h3
forcing black to capture on f3 or to
move back but the main move is to
capture here so captures queen captures
and now e6 the light square bishop has
been traded off so now you want to put
your pawns on light squares
uh g3 hikaru makes room uh for
finn carrying the light square bishop he
also wants to castle the safety
and the bishop to c5 with bishop to g2
and now knight to e7 both players are
now ready to castle
uh and they do so castles castles and
here hikaru goes queen to e2 and this
queen to e2 is a new move
uh so already as of move nine we have a
completely new game
queen to e2 is on the board knights the
d7
mommy jarv also continues development
and now d3
now you can play some like king h2 push
this pawn to f4 maybe develop the bishop
uh and so on so here king to h8 uh and
now comes
knights the a4 putting pressure on mommy
there's a bishop here
bishop back to d6 and now d4 so
if you don't want to meet e5 and well
this will pretty much render this dark
square bishop useless for the rest of
the game
you kind of have to capture and this is
what mamadara does we have the captures
on e4
queen captures on e4 and now knight the
g6
uh we have knight back to c3 by hikaru
the knight isn't
now doing all that much here uh so we we
have to reactivate it knight's the c3
and queen to e7 now
mom video connects the rooks and they
are now ready to also
join the game and now queen to e2 by
hikaru getting the queen to a bit of a
more safer square you are kind of
expecting knight f6 so
there's no reason for this to come with
tempo the queen will be much safer there
and now rook 8 e8 with h4 by hikaru now
hikaru here is threatening h5
and if you uh if you're paying attention
to what's happening all of these squares
are taken so the knight really doesn't
have an escape square h5 will trap the
knight so here
mamidor finds a very interesting way of
meeting this and he plays
e5 now the point is if h5 is played then
i'm just going to capture on d4 and
i'm going to be attacking your knight as
well but here hikaro finds a very strong
d5 and d5
is very very problematic for black
because obviously you don't want to
capture and allow white to this
beautiful outpost but you
kind of don't have the option of not
capturing because if you do nothing then
also
just winning a pawn here is possible uh
but worst of all if you try and block
the position then
h5 again becomes an option and you lose
a piece
so instead after d5 we have e4 mommy
durov decides all right we're not gonna
start defending or playing some weird
moves
we're just gonna uh start playing in
great style and
move forward so e4 and now hikaru needs
to
decide whether he wants to capture you
can't really capture it with the knight
or the bishop because then f5
just you know is problematic the queen
on e2 will be unguarded
uh but queen captures is a possibility
hikaru however first captures on c6
with b captures and only now queen
captures an e4
so just grabbing material nothing wrong
with that and here
knight d to e5 and okay uh madaro is now
down material but
maybe he can stir some trouble yeah and
here queen f5
is very very strong for hikaru it's an
uh excellent square for the queen also
prevents the pawn from coming to f5
and you can start bringing your pieces
into the game he car starts with
h5 but the disallows uh well
maybe not not all that um
uh powerful of a move but it is the only
move that gives mahmoud any fighting
chances and this is f5
that's why queen to f5 was um was a bit
stronger but let's not forget this is a
three minute game so uh of course we
cannot expect
uh players to always uh play the best
movie as they would for example in
classical or in rapid chess
uh for for those of you who are maybe
new to chess uh you might uh
be wondering such things because
sometimes i show a game it's a three
minute game and then people ask like oh
how can a 2800 player play something
like this
it's a three-minute game and you know
they're spending you know
seconds sometimes even fractions of a
second to make a move
so queen to a4 getting the queen out of
the way and now comes
knight the g4 and this is a super
impressive move by mamadirov
point is if he just continues his attack
with f4 which is possible
and sacrifices a piece we would see
something like f captures on g3
f captures queen c sorry bishop c5 with
check
and now you have to move king h1 we're
gonna play rook captures on f1 bishop
captures
and the okay white is still better here
but i mean it's such an ugly position to
play that uh not a lot of people would
play this
you know in a three-minute blitz game so
instead after queen to a4 uh we have
knight the g4 by mama darv he now offers
the knight this way
uh hikaru grabs it and now comes not f4
a move that you might be expecting but
rather bishop captures than g3 so
mabujarov just continues happily
sacrificing pieces
uh and now again what do you do here
here hikaru accepts
uh the problem is this is not the uh the
best way to go
bishop to f4 is the way to go and it's
just such an
ugly move to meet when you're attacking
with black and have already sacrificed
material there's no defense against this
uh i mean if you try any checkmating
ideas just bishop captures on g3 and all
of your hopes uh go
go out the window so here you really
don't have a good move bishop f4
is just uh you know there's nothing to
play
if you capture queen captures again
there's no way to to continue this any
queen to h4
moves are pretty much pointless because
the queen already covers all of this
so black's attack is not happening here
but you know that's the beauty of
playing uh uh beautiful chess uh
when um you're playing three minute
blitz games uh
your opponent does not have the time to
find uh such subtlety so here if
captures on g3 was played
and now queen to c5 with check that only
one
a good move for for hikaru here king to
h1
and now now comes the uh the the
beautiful
f4 and this is just amazing uh because
it opens up
this uh queen to h5 with check so hikaru
finds the only move that
allows him to basically continue the
game uh uh uh
well you could also play something like
knights to d5 and simply offer a piece
to block
uh but he car plays bishop to h3 and
this is the
the the absolute best way and here
hikaru has some one minute and 20
seconds on the clock whereas momodaro
has some one minute and 45 seconds so
the pressure is rising so here we have
rook to e1
the rook the e1 is such an amazing move
the problem here is
after queen to h5 king g2 and uh the
attack is over there's simply no no good
way to continue the attack but here
after mamadou's rook to e1 now the
the the pressure is on hikaru again
because even though the rook can be
captured it's
it's not a free rook because now there
is no rook to cover the f3 square and
now queen to h5 is deadly because now if
the same idea king g2 now f3 check and
there is no rook to pick up the f3 pawn
after you move queen captures it will
end in checkmate okay you can prolong
with rookie two but
we said long ago that we will not cover
such lines
so problem is after rook to e1 there is
again only
one good move here and that is queen
captures on f4 but
this was not played in the game this
beautiful queen sacrifice
uh well you you have to give back some
material you're already up so much
material you have to give up the queen
uh the problem is if uh black accepts
the queen for example with rook captures
honey
on f4 then you play rook captures on e1
threatening uh some nasty ideas here
okay for the moment the rook and queen
are guarding the f8 square but your rook
is under attack by the pawn and by the
bishop
so here we could see a lot of things
like knight f2 check king g2 now rook
back to f8 but now rook to f1
and again there's so much pressure uh
it's
impossible to hold this if queen h5
again doesn't matter rook captures on f2
rook captures king captures queen
captures
but now bishop f4 and still white has
two pieces uh two
two pieces a rook and you know a very
good position to play
uh black will not be able to do all that
much here with the queen
uh but okay this was not played in the
game after this rook the e1 we're still
on rook to e1 yes
uh here uh uh hikaru actually played
bishop captures on f4 and now now he
allows
mamijarov a beautiful move that that is
completely winning for him
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this move for black
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
uh crushing hikaru who who does seem to
be immortal here
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen to f2 this is
what mom and dad have played and
there is no defense against this of
course the queen cannot be captured
as the rook is spinning it and if you
try something weird like
well there's there's really not all that
much to try here
you're getting checkmated because queen
the h2 will be checkmate the knight
covers that square and of course the
knight
also cannot be captured because then
nothing is defending the rook just queen
captures followed by queen to g2 will be
checkmate or
rather queen to g2 will be checkmate so
not an option here so hikaru finds the
only way to to keep the game going and
that's bishop to g2
but now comes rook to f5 another
excellent move by mom
yeah rook the h5 check is coming so here
again hikaru finds us a move that's so
weird and you know the the only way to
uh you know
uh show some uh resilience and that's
bishop to g5 uh
offering a full piece just uh prolonged
the game a little bit but it also comes
with
with some poison attached to it because
if you capture the bishop
like this then queen captures and g4
comes and now you have problems
uh there's no longer rook h5 the queen
covers that and if you accept the queen
then rook a captures on a1 and now what
do you do here you have to move the
queen and all of the rooks are ready to
check mated the black king
this is hopeless for black so here uh
bishop to g5 an amazing defensive
resource by hikaru but mamedyarov
doesn't fall for it he plays queen
captures on g3
now again queen to h2 the threat of
checkmate it seems like it's all over
but hikaru
finds a way to continue the game queen
captures on g4 now
hikaru gives up the queen to continue
the attack and that there is only one
good move for for mahmoud here and i i
could ask you to find it but
the every move in this game could be a
pause the video moment so yeah i'm just
gonna show it to you
uh the point is you have to capture on
f1 but what with
uh do you capture with this rook or do
you capture with this rook
uh the correct thing to do is to capture
with the e-rook rookie captures here and
then
black is just winning uh point is that
after rook captures and rook captures
with check
bishop captures now we trade and now we
capture the queen queen captures on g4
and now uh well you have to save the
bishop bishop to d2 and then you're
gonna pick up this pawn let's say queen
h5 check king g1 queen captures here
and yes you do have three pieces for a
queen but it's uh it's an open board and
the the black queen should be able to
pick up all of these pawns and then just
you know you use the pawns to advance
them to victory
but this is if this was for example a
classical or a rapid game in a
three-minute blitz game
not so much so here mamidarov did not go
for rook captures or rather he did but
he played with the other rook he played
rook f captures on f1
which seems to be even stronger but it's
not uh because now uh we have bishop
captures on f1
and here you have this is the the last
chance you have to play queen characters
on g4
uh and i'll go for this rook capture sun
e1 and now of course queen h5 checking
do you want let's say queen captures
with
check bishop g2 and try and play this
out now it's not
queen against three pieces it's queen
against two pieces and the rook uh so
now white should be able to draw this
without without much problems
uh the problem is mamidera played rook
captures on f1 with
check he wanted to uh delete uh you know
exchange this one as well and then
capture the queen but now to his horror
hikaru just captured
the rook on f1 but now there's a problem
this rook is now on f1
and well he's aiming at that a very very
uh unfortunate
f8 square for mahmud jarov so he was
also in this position on move 31 that
shakir mamidar resigned the game and as
there is nothing more to be done here
whatever you play you're either getting
checkmated or you're you know down
so much material that it would be
pointless of course if the queen is
captured this is just mate in one
and if you don't do this you have to
defend against checkmate somehow but
then
you know i mean look how much material
you're down any move wins here you're
threatening checkmate
any of this you can just capture and
still check mate the black king not
nothing to it
uh so really uh a beautiful game by both
of them amiro really uh
started the attack in a spectacular way
uh here
after all of this was played i mean just
this uh first sacrificing the knight and
then following it up with bishop
captures and g3
we could see this also in slow motion
this bishop captures on g3
really i i mean spectacular so
this is an attacking game from the start
but you know it's hard to say
who's attacking who at what point in the
game so
really really an awesome game especially
for a three plus zero i mean
uh so many so many uh wild wild lines
that uh
like i said we could make a positive
video moment out of uh
every move for white and black so yeah
after rook captures and if one major
saw that uh okay i'm not i'm not even
you know even in the game anymore
whatever i played this is just checkmate
and it was of course in this position
that chakrimamida resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said
do check out the first link in the
description below it will take you to
mamidarov's channel so you can check it
out
if you guys are interested in that like
i said he just created it so it's it's a
very new channel
so do check it out uh i would like to
thank henry baumslot
adam doug uh uh dougal
uh shocker good friend uh harry lewin
and mr hoodie guy for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day